let's hear directly now from Doc dr.
Shulkin he joins us mister secretary
thanks for being here glad to be here
Brett so let's start with this why do
you think you were fired
well every cabinet member serves at the
pleasure of the president and it's the
president's prerogative to have a team
around him that he thinks is doing the
job I think we heard today from the
president that he wasn't happy with the
pace and you know I agree with the
president this is a organization that
needs to change it needs to do better at
his job and we all want to do it faster
and better because it's so important to
the country and I think the president
has the right to have the secretary that
he wants with him you said the
administration wants to privatize the VA
have you ever seen we haven't seen
evidence of as far as White House policy
directives sent to Congress saying that
is there any direct communication with
Congress that the administration wants
to privatize the VA no Brett I actually
haven't said that I'm I was part of the
administration until yesterday we are
not trying to privatize the VA we are
trying to improve and transform the VA
what I said in my editorial is is that
there are a number of political
appointees within VA that are pushing to
privatize much faster than I think is in
the interests of veterans and is the
safe way to care for our veterans and
I've I've stood up for them because I
was in Washington and I was working for
the president on behalf of our veterans
why did you feel the need to write the
op-ed well listen I think it's important
I came to Washington from the private
sector for one reason to fix the VA I
know this matters a lot to the president
and we as a country have a long way to
go to get the VA in improper shape but
it would be a mistake to conclude that
we do not need the VA and that we have
to dismantle the VA we have to improve
the VA while at the same time working
with the private sector in an integrated
way to meet the needs of our veterans
you know we heard the sound bite in
Lucas's piece from Senator Moran
questioning your dealings with that
particular committee did you have a
credibility issue with Congress oh I
don't think so
you have to remember I'm the only
cabinet member that had a hundred to
zero vote
I've prided myself in working in a
bipartisan way senator Moran felt
strongly about pushing to give veterans
additional options that frankly his own
senators the committee didn't agree with
he lost his amendment 14 to 1 he was the
only one voting against it and he was
frustrated by that and by the way you
know he had some reasonable points there
so there are many things that he and I
agreed upon but in the end he didn't
like the position that I took which was
to do what I thought was the right thing
for our veterans about 11 months ago I
had you on special report we were
talking about the challenges take a
listen
have things changed are you seeing
change were in the intensive care unit
and we're monitoring things really
closely but I am optimistic that we're
beginning to finally deal with the
issues that have plagued the VA system
for decades so the president said today
that he just wasn't happy how fast or
how things were going that they were
going too slowly what's your response to
that and what can be get done to change
that pace well I don't think the
president should be happy with where we
were and as Secretary I wasn't happy
with where we were we have to figure out
how to move this bureaucracy faster and
be more responsive when you showed the
virata's I know Michael and Sarah very
well and frankly this was a system that
failed them and we shouldn't be doing
that so so this is a system that needs
to be pushed many of the bureaucratic
elements need to be restructured I've
started that process I hope that dr.
Jackson will continue that process
because it needs to be done you know you
had the Inspector General obviously come
out with this scathing report about
about your trip to Europe we've been
over that and your response to that
we're there other IG investigations or
audits that that we're factoring into
this whole thing well you know
Washington is a town that throws up all
sorts of allegations there were
allegations of additional reports but
there have been no other reports that
have come out and I've addressed that
everything
I did on this European trip was
pre-approved by ethics was consistent
with past policies at VA but when the
Inspector General had concerns about it
I wrote a check and I paid back every
penny of a single coach airfare that was
the total amount that that government
funds were used for and I paid that back
so look I think I've addressed that this
was used in a political way to try to
remove me and you know this is
Washington I'm a big I'm a big boy I
understand that I've said that it
shouldn't be this hard to serve your
country and I don't think it should be
but thankfully there are many people
that are still trying to fix our systems
like the VA so if you had a message for
the incoming secretary should he get
confirmed what would it be
Oh take two you know make sure that he's
consistent with the president's agenda
to push really hard always to keep the
veterans interests at heart to make sure
that he's working closely with Congress
and a bipartisan way VA cannot afford to
be politicized and make sure that he's
listening to the veteran groups because
frankly that's why we're doing this
that's what a responsive organization
needs to be successful in doing is
listening to those that it serves so I
will help dr. Jackson in any way that he
needs help because it's very important
that we succeed at this mission mr.
secretary thank you for your service not
an easy interview on this day we
appreciate your time thank you Brett